there are plenty of smaller venues
around town that have been safely
keeping vegas style entertainment alive
during the pandemic
brock redkey editor at large for las
vegas weekly joining us to chat about it
brock these are mostly offstrip venues
that you're profiling this week correct
that's right there's a lot of
uh restaurants bars and lounge style
videos
all over the valley that have been doing
live music during this time
but i wanted to focus on some just a few
smaller venues and theaters that have
been really stacking different kinds of
entertainment programming
uh pretty much this whole year yeah we
covered the comedians just last week
which was awesome to chat about
so let's get started with a smaller
venue called the space what do they have
to offer
the space uh is just behind the strip
like right behind the cosmopolitan
and uh i think their greatest innovation
during this time
is incorporating live stream shows uh
into their programming so when things
opened back up again and they were
allowed to have small crowds
they did that as well but they were
already live streaming shows so
during that complete shutdown period
they had like strip headliners like the
righteous brothers
and the bronx wanderers doing uh live
stream shows that were being viewed
from all across the country live from
las vegas which is pretty cool
that is really cool gets them out there
even more so right
some positives all right well how about
brock some old vegas lounge style
entertainment where can folks find that
right now
yeah another place that has been really
popular during the last year is the
vegas room it's still a new venue
it's in commercial center on east sahara
and they are doing
these really intimate uh small shows
dinner shows and brunch on sundays and
same thing they're getting a lot of
entertainers who are in you know have
been regular gigs on the strip
in lounges or in production shows and
now these performers
are going to the vegas room creating
these really personal shows
and it's quite the experience of
something special over there at the
vegas room
i gotta say brock i don't know what it
is about las vegas but people here love
their brunches you mentioned that and
that was never a thing for me and you
know my 25 years of tv
moving here eight years ago everybody
loves their brunch
yeah that's a lot of fun another cool
thing about the vegas room is they
really build their
build themselves as a listening room
they're really focused on the
performance
so even brunch you know which is kind of
crazy in las vegas
if you go to the vegas room you get
served as great food great drinks
and then the service stops and then the
performance starts so that everyone can
really focus and it's better for the
artist that way too
so yeah unique experience brock with 15
seconds left what do we have at the
alexis park resort
the alexis park resort has every kind of
vegas show you can think of magic
comedy uh musical tributes they just
started a new
family friendly show and i don't think
most people you know the lexus park
resort doesn't have a casino
so it's a it's a smaller quieter
property but there's a lot going
on there right now wonderful thanks so
much for your time
brock we greatly appreciate that please
pick up a copy of las vegas weekly at
your nearest convenience thanks brock
we'll talk to you next week